it's lying to women when we're saying  like statistically they're like for  example when you when you sleep with  more men you lose your ability to pair  bond so you have a harder time bonding  with your husband later on like the  person that you marry and there's a  million studies that'll back this up  yeah people you sleep with the less like  you you have a higher probability of  being divorced yeah yeah so so saying to  women Empower yourself and sleep with  whoever you I'm not I'm not saying women  should be prude well everyone wants to  get married and not everyone wants to be  power wounded not everyone and not  everyone is scared of divorced no and  that's that's fine and so but I think we  should give women all of the information  oh yeah